[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm here at the interval in san
francisco where i'll be joined remotely
by our speaker today wade davis this is
the second talk that wade davis has
given in our series the first one was on
indigenous technologies and how that's
useful in the modern world
and today he's going to be talking about
the field of anthropology and where
it's come from where it's going and
really maybe how it can help
the world that we're living in today
welcome wade davis
well thanks very alexander and thanks to
the long now foundation it's wonderful
work you do and it's great to be back
part of a
part of your family and i'd like to um
share a story with you today that may
seem like a small
matter a kind of a a tempest and an
academic teapot if you will but it's one
with
significant ramifications if we are ever
to truly live
in a kind of pluralistic multicultural
world
now ruth benedict the acolyte of the
great franz boaz
and in 1947 the president of the
american anthropological association
reputedly said that the very purpose
of anthropology was to make the world
safe
for human differences in the immediate
wake of 9 11 and i was living in
washington dc at the time
the american anthropological association
actually met
in the nation's capital 4 000
anthropologists were in washington
in the wake of the biggest story of
culture
they or the entire country would ever
face
the entire gathering earned but a
mention
in the washington post newspaper in the
gossip section
in the style section a few lines that
essentially reported
that the nut cases were back in town
and it was hard to know who was more
remiss
the government for failing to listen to
the one
profession that could have answered the
question then on the lips
of all americans why do they hate us
or the profession itself for failing to
reach beyond itself to bring its
considerable insights and wisdom to the
attention
of the nation perhaps
fittingly it took an outsider to remind
anthropologists why anthropology matters
charles king a professor of
international affairs at georgetown
university
begins this remarkable book of his by
asking us a very
to kind of participate in a very simple
thought experiment
to just envision the world as it was
in the lives of our grandparents perhaps
your
great-grandparents now think for a
moment about
how it was in edwardian england or
america at the time before the
first world war race
charles notes was accepted as a given a
biological fact
with lineages dividing white from black
that reached back through
primordial time differences in customs
and beliefs reflected
differences in intelligence and destiny
with every culture
finding its place on a on a rung of an
evolutionary ladder that went from the
savage to the barbarian
to the civilized of the strand of london
with technological wizardry
the great achievement of the west being
the sole measure
of progress and success sexual and
behavioral characteristics were fixed
whites were smart
and industrious and some people were
barely people at all
incredibly as recently as 1902 in the
lifetime
of my grandfather it was debated in
melbourne australia
as to whether or not the aboriginal
peoples of australia
were in fact human or not women's
suffrage
only came in 1919 three years after the
birth
of my father immigrants in almost all
nations
were seen as a threat even by those who
had only recently themselves
clawed their way ashore the poor
of course were responsible for their own
miseries
as for the blind the deaf the dumb the
cripples and the mad
they were best locked away lobotomized
or even killed to remove them
from the gene pool in the time of my
grandfather
the superiority of the white male was
accepted with such assurance
that the concise oxford english
dictionary published in 1911
had no entries for racism or colonialism
interracial marriage remained illegal
in much of the united states until 1967.
now here we are two generations
later and it goes without saying that no
educated person would share any of these
bankrupt certitudes that i've now listed
all of which raises a question
what was it that allowed our culture
to go from zero to 60 in a generation
now all of those were political
movements but political movements are
built
fundamentally on the possibility of
change
and the catalyst as charles king reminds
us
in his wonderful book was the wisdom
and scientific genius of franz
boaz and a small band of courageous
scholars
margaret mead alfred krober elsie
cluells
parsons melva herskovitz edward sapir
robert lowry ruth benedict the
incomparable zorro neil hurston and many
others
contrarians all who came into his orbit
destined to change the world
and we today live in the social
landscape
of their dreams the scientific
realization that humanity
is one interconnected and
undivided whole now widely
acknowledged as a father of american
cultural anthropology
franz boaz was the first scholar to
explore
in a truly open and neutral manner how
human
social perceptions are formed and how
members of distinct societies
become conditioned to see and interpret
the world
far far ahead of his times doing his
field work
in the 1880s boaz recognized that
every distinct social community was a
unique
facet of the human legacy and its
promise
each was a product of its own history
none existed in some absolute sense
we create our social realms boaz would
say
determine what we then define as being
common sense
universal truths the appropriate rules
and codes of behavior
beauty really does lie in the eye of the
beholder
manners don't make the man men and women
invent the manners race
and gender are cultural constructs
derived not from biology but born
in the realm of ideas now critically
none of this implied an extreme
relativism
as if every human behavior had to be
accepted simply because it exists boaz
never called for the elimination of
judgment
only its suspension so the very
judgments that we're obliged to make
ethically and morally
as human beings may be informed ones
now boaz has come in for a lot of
criticism in the kind of
revisionist era of anthropology and he
was by no means a perfect man
as wendy wickwire's brilliant recent
book on james tate suggests
boaz could be petty vainglorious
fiercely ambitious insecure
unacknowledged
jealous covetous slow to share credit
both threatened by and resentful of
anyone else's success
but all of that said in 1883
he lived on baffin island for two
12-month periods a participant observer
in the fullest sense
completely dependent on his inuit
companions
eating what they ate wearing what they
wore
and traveling as they traveled by dog
sled
and small boat in 1898
he was one of the first to speak out
against
the potlatch ban in the pacific
northwest
he spoke out from the earliest days
against
the residential schools just as he spoke
out in favor
of the rights of the native american
church to use peyote
in its sacred ceremonies in 1911
when again to remind you the oxford
english dictionary did not even have an
entry for racism boaz wrote
there is no fundamental difference in
the ways of thinking
of so-called primitive and civilized man
a connection between race and
personality has never been established
the concept of racial type as commonly
used in the scientific literature
is misleading and wrong achievements of
races do not warrant us to assume
that one race can possibly be more
gifted
than another as a mentor
and a teacher he supported zora neale
hurston
a black woman in the 1920s who got her
phd by studying the richness of black
folkloric culture in the american south
his support for ella deloria
a dakota woman was equally strong and
exceptional
as for colonialism and the treatment of
native people
he wrote in 1919 any policy that
increases production of valuable raw
products by exploitation of the country
that destroys the social life
of the natives must be condemned
it is obvious that fair and decent
policies will never be introduced so
long as colonies
and their inhabitants are considered
property of colonial powers
that exploit the land and utilize their
inhabitants only for their own
economic purposes and for fighting their
battles
now this at a time when teddy roosevelt
revered today in the american
conservation movement
was dismissing native americans as quote
a pestilence to be removed from the body
of america
inspired by his time amongst the inuit
on baffin island and his
later work amongst the quakawak in the
salmon forest of the pacific northwest
he informed all who would listen that
the other peoples of the world
were not failed attempts to be them
failed attempts to be modern
now here's the amazing part franz boaz
would not live to see his insights and
intuitions confirmed by hard science
let alone define the zeitgeist of a new
global culture
in many ways his intuition about
cultural relativism was just a
poetic flourish a thought a hope a dream
a prayer
for the well-being of humanity but today
80 years on
and long after his death studies of the
human genome
have indeed revealed that the genetic
endowment of humanity
is a continuum race has been exposed
as an utter fiction but here is the
really extraordinary idea
and this is what he understood in his
heart and his soul and in his mind
if we are all cut from the same fabric
of life
then by definition all peoples all
cultures share the same
mental acuity the same raw genius
and whether that intellectual potential
is exercised through technological
innovation as has been the great
achievement of the west
or through the untangling of the complex
threads of memory
inherent in a myth is simply
a matter of choice and orientation
adaptive insights and cultural emphasis
there is no hierarchy of progress
in the history of culture no
evolutionary
ladder to success boaz and his students
were right the brilliance of scientific
research
the revelations of modern genetics has
affirmed
an astonishing way both the unity of
humanity
and the essential wisdom of cultural
relativism
every culture really does have something
to say each deserves to be heard
just as none as a monopoly on the root
to the divine
but what does this actually mean for us
how how can we see this
become expressed in studies of culture
well let's slip now into the culture
sphere that is most antithetical to that
of the west
we find ourselves in the great
civilization of australia
we know from studies of the y chromosome
that the ancestors of the australian
aborigines were the very first human
people to walk out of africa and in ten
thousand years
they established ten thousand clan
territories all
linked by a single idea and that is a
dreaming
the song lines now the dreaming wasn't a
dream
it was the idea of the earth both exists
and is waiting to be formed now when the
british washed ashore
on that distant cotton in the late 18th
century they met a people
that looked strange who had a simple
material technology
but what really offended the british was
that nowhere
where they went in no tribal society of
australia
did they ever encounter anybody who had
any interest whatsoever
in improving upon their material lot
the british took great offense and in
their inimicable way
decided that the aboriginal people
weren't people at all
and indeed they began to shoot them and
as i said earlier in 1902 it was debated
in parliament as to whether or not
aboriginal people were human in the
1950s
ranchers in australia had had a quotas
as
of as to how many abos could be shot who
trespassed upon their lands as recently
as 1960s when i was a schoolboy
a book used in schools across australia
a treasury of fauna of australia
included the aborigines as amongst the
interesting forms of wildlife in the
continent
what was actually going on was a
devotional philosophy too subtle for the
british to understand and that was a
dream in and the whole point of the
dreaming was the antithesis of progress
it was stasis it was constancy the
entire idea was to
not change anything but rather to do the
ritual jesters
along the song line which is a
trajectory walked at the dawn of time
by the ancestral beings who sang the
universe into existence
and to do the ritual gestures deemed to
be necessary to keep the world exactly
as it was at the time of its creation
and now the
issue is not to say who's right and
who's wrong had humanity as a whole
followed that intellectual devotion we
wouldn't have put a man on the moon
but on the other hand we wouldn't be
talking about global climate change
and our capacity to transform the bio
physical
and biological support systems of the
entire planet
so this is what the anthropological lens
can can show us let's slip for a moment
into the greatest culture seer ever
brought into being by the human
imagination
and that of course is polynesia tens of
thousands of islands flung upon
the southern seas 10 centuries before
christ
long before european transports had the
nerve to
sail away from the shores of continents
the ancestors of the polynesians set
sail into the rising sun
and just using celestial navigation
the signs and symbols and messages of
nature
they settle the greatest culture sphere
on the planet
such that you could say today that every
uh thing of the human genius that
allowed us to put a man on the moon if
you applied that to
the oceans what you would get is
polynesia
and how about our relationship to the
planet itself
you know climate change has become
humanity's problem
it wasn't caused by humanity it was
caused by a narrow
subset of humanity that for 300 years
has been consuming the ancient
sunlight of the world you know all
cultures
are myopic faithful to their own
interpretation of reality
and we too are products of our own
history and culture
when in the renaissance and into the
enlightenment
we tried desperately to liberate
ourselves from the tyranny of absolute
faith
when descartes famously said that all
that existed
is mind and material with a single
gesture he deanimated the world and
flung out all notions of myth magic
mysticism and metaphor
to the extent that saul bella would
write science made a house cleaning
of belief and the earth became to be
seen as just a stage set upon which only
the human drama
unfolded we developed a kind of an
extractive model
whereby if the flight of a bird had no
meaning a mountain was mere material and
rock
ready to be mined most peoples around
the world
have established relationships with the
natural world based not on extractive
principles
but on reciprocity some kind of
iteration of the fundamental idea that
the earth owes its bounty to people
people in turn owe their fidelity to the
earth
and that simple equation elaborated
through ritual
and belief has a profound consequence in
terms of the ecological footprint of a
people
i like many of you was raised to believe
that a mountain
existed of rock ready to be mined that a
forest was cellulose
ready to be cut the point is it's not
whether a mountain is
rock or as a spirit it's how the
metaphor plays out
in the relationship between human beings
and the natural world
most societies around the world see the
earth as
alive they see it as a force to be
engaged and
and filtered through the human
imagination and
all of this was made possible because
boaz and his cadre came along
to shatter the conventions of european
conceit it was a shattering of the
european mind the sociological
equivalent
of splitting the atom and they're
remembered today at least by those of us
who revere them
as the giants of the discipline boaz
and his students margaret mead ruth
benedict all of them
zora neale hurston were in their time
dismissed from jobs because of their
activism
denied promotion because of their
beliefs harassed by the fbi as the
subversives
they truly were and attacked in the
press
simply for being different and yet
they stood their ground he would never
sit back in silence as fully half
the languages of the world hover on the
brink of extinction
implying the loss in a single generation
of fully half
of humanity's social ecological and
spiritual knowledge
to those who suggest that indigenous
people are destined to fade away
he would reply that change in technology
is no threat to culture
but power is cultures under threat are
neither fragile
nor vestigial in every instance they are
living dynamic peoples being driven
out of existence by identifiable forces
that for him was an optimistic
observation because if
human beings are the agents of cultural
destruction
we can be and must be the facilitators
of cultural survival
so anthropology matters as it always has
because it allows us to look under the
surface of things
the very existence of other ways of
being other ways of thinking
other visions of life itself puts
a lie to those of us in our own culture
who say for example that we cannot
change as we surely know we must
the fundamental way in which we inhabit
this planet
and as the events of the last years have
shown
the struggle long ago championed by
franz boaz
is lamentably ongoing
never never has a voice of anthropology
being more important but it must be
spoken
to be heard so why isn't it being heard
or i
deliberately moved away from the
academic life in 1986 soon after
receiving my own phd and only returned
to the academic fold when offered quite
unexpectedly
a university tenured professorship in
2013
when i was 59 years old and i don't know
what happened
but all i can report is that in that
time
anthropology turned inward largely
abandoning its roots and activism
after three decades of what i can only
call
flagellation and almost nihilistic
self-absorption
an outsider could be forgiven for
thinking that contemporary
anthropologists
mostly study themselves
now certainly in the beginning as all
disciplines do
there was reasons for critiques reasons
to
rethink the history and plenty to
criticize
in the history of anthropology hovering
of course over british and
french social anthropology in particular
was always the shadows of a
colonial past you know men in pith
helmets literally dispatched to
understand and interpret the ways of
people that had come
under the rule of colonial authorities
and of course there was also in many of
these
classic situations of a foreign scholar
and a local people
a kind of power dynamic that could be
manipulated and i can only say that if
someone turned up at my house here on
this small island british columbia
and announced that i was going to house
and feed them for
a year and they're here to study my
private life
i call the police and so perhaps it was
inevitable that
as in the way of scholarship a new
generation of scholars would come to
question the certitudes of a previous
generation but it seems to me that
in anthropology it became too much
things got out of hand the baby
was tossed out with the bathwater
legitimate concerns and critiques
tumbled one upon the other until the
very rationale of the discipline was
being called
into question cannibalized by
revisionist contempt
for its elders reduced to the
intellectual equivalent
of the circular firing squad
my experience in anthropology as a
storyteller
traveling the world was very different
when i applied to the nsf
for grants to study the secret societies
at the time
notorious in the literature i received
the money but it was annotated
on my academic grant application that if
i tried to do this work i would be
killed i never felt for a moment
that was the case but the point is even
if it had been the case
it wouldn't have made a difference
because the mission was more
important at that time than any
particular
challenges faced by the individual
scholar
so for me anthropology has always been
about activism
here is a world where people die for
years working with the penang to help
protect the forests of sarawak
in the face of the greatest and most
intense industrial deforestation
ever to occur in the world and bruno
manser our dear friend and comrade
murdered by the chinese loggers and yet
ian mckenzie
my close friend with whom i wrote a book
a linguist who's devoted himself to that
people that language
and every year since 1993 has returned
to spend six months in the forest to
chronicle
that tongue that language that wisdom
that tradition or my friend alberto
villafana
a leader of the arawaka was murdered by
the parakos
in colombia yet today his son is the
leader
of the arawaka nation tibetan scholar i
traveled 6 000 kilometers width from
chengdu
to lhasa and only when we reached the
ancient tibetan
capital did i learn the story of his
family his
father murdered by the red guard when
the
maoist took over lhasa in 1959 his uncle
escorted
his holiness to freedom in nepal
his mother imprisoned for the sin of
being wealthy
he as a little boy smuggled into the
prison where he spent months beneath her
dress hidden away because she needed to
be with him
and the sister who did that brave deed
put into a maoist concentration camp
during the cultural revolution and
she stepped inadvertently one day on a
maoist armband that had slipped off
the sleeve of an adjacent worker and for
that transgression was given
seven years of hard labor this is the
real
front lines of anthropology my friend
martin
hildebrand to whom i dedicate my most
recent book
martine a young student of anthropology
paddles down the pita parana
after he graduates in the 1960s you come
upon the hut
where he finds an old man still paying
off
the cost of a treadle sewing machines 50
years after it was bartered
to owned by a rubber baron he
immediately
stops establishes a rubber company that
will give the indigenous people fair and
just
prices for their product he studies the
mukul language
he becomes one as a tanimoko and then he
does his phd and then he becomes head of
indian affairs and in 1985
the president of columbia vegeta says to
martin martine do something for the
indians and in five incredible years
martin does more than something he
secures legal land tenure
for an area of land collectively the
size of the united kingdom
for the 57 ethnicities of the northwest
amazon
land rights encoded in perpetuity in the
1991 constitution of the country and
then behind a veil of isolation
created by the conflict of modern
colombia
a whole new dream of culture is born
stephen hugh jones
who lived with the bharasana and his
wife christine in 1968
who revealed their world to us a world
that we would not know
of a world in which the most profound
spiritual intuition is the idea that
plants and animals are just people
in another dimension of reality a realm
of mythology that is a land management
plan that dictates precisely how people
can live with doing no harm to the
forest
he was one of the anthropologists who
predicted the disappearance
of the barasana lamentably in 1968
and he flies back in to join us in a
film project
he walks into a longhouse sees 250 men
in full ritual regalia
celebrating the fertility of cassava
woman he can't believe his eyes and he
gets
on the satellite phone to his wife
christine back in london
and he says i can't believe it the only
thing that disappeared my love
are the [ __ ] missionaries and so what
happened
is that politics changed the land went
back and when we asked some elders
why they accepted the um the presence of
these missionaries for so long who were
doing so much harm
they said something very meaningful and
profound
why did we accept them because they
promised to make us
human and that is the essence of of
colonialism to persuade the colonized
of their own inherent inferiority
and that is a cycle the anthropologist
broke and helped to break and martine
has stood as a companion a comrade
a brother of all the peoples of
northwest amazon
so if we move to the arctic and the
legendary newt rasmussen a
son of a danish missionary a mother of
inuit blood
who moved effortlessly between the
social and cultural realms he knew the
language
from birth he ran his own dogs at the
age of nine
from an outpost in northern greenland he
launched seven research
expeditions between 1912 and 1933 that
explored the length of greenland
and on the greatest of all crossed all
of north america 20
000 miles to point barrow alaska an
expedition
unparalleled since that of lewis and
clark now he didn't take these journeys
with endurance records in mind he had no
interest in being the first to do
anything
his ambitions had nothing to do with
self
travel allowed him to enter the inuit
world through the only portal
then available to him shared experience
on the open tundra
his holy grail was not a place an object
but a state of mind
a depth of understanding that would
allow him to reveal
to the world the wonder of inuit life
stretching across
all the circumpolar expanses a common
culture of the northern ice people
speaking dialects of the same language
sharing beliefs
and myths responding to the same
adaptive imperatives only one
who had physically crossed on foot from
greenland
to alaska could report as he did
that a youth in greenland would
recognize a tale
told by a grandfather on the northern
slope of alaska just as an elder
there would know the folklore of the
polar eskimo
of northwest greenland and though a
child
of the arctic an adopted son of the
inuit
rasmussen never abandoned his
obligations as a scholar
the research expedition of the fifth
tool a published in 1946
fields 10 volumes 6 000 pages
20 000 artifacts this extraordinary
source that today is the
invaluable portrait of the inuit before
sustained
and corrosive contact began in the 1950s
and with his wizardly gift for languages
and his well-honed ethnographic eye
rasmussen never doubted that the true
glory of the arctic resided not
in the landscape not in this meaningless
point called the north pole
but in the genius and the vision of the
inuit
his life mission was to know the world
as they did
to understand the patterns of their
lives to enter their realms of magic
and shamanic power with knowledge as his
goal
cultural understanding the quest
rasmussen completely redefined
the promise and potential of exploration
not to mention
ethnography the point is that
anthropology
exists not to tear people apart
but to bring them together it's not
about the traditional
versus the modern it's it's about the
rights of free people everywhere
to choose the components of their lives
it's certainly not about freezing people
in time like some kind of zoological
specimen as if they're frozen in the
past
it's about asking ourselves what kind of
world do we all want to live in
how can we all find a way that all
peoples everywhere
benefit from the genius of science and
modernity
but without that engagement demanding
the death of who they are as a people
and the reason for this is clear it's
not an issue of nostalgia
romance even human rights it's about
geopolitical stability
because culture is not trivial culture
is not superficial culture is not the
songs we sing
the prayers we utter the clothes we wear
the dances
we do culture ultimately is a body of
ethical and moral values
that every culture places around each
individual within that culture
to keep at bay the barbaric heart that
history sadly teaches us
lies within all human beings it is
culture that allows us to make sense out
of sensation
find order and meaning in the universe
to do as lincoln said
in his first inaugural address to seek
the better angels
always of our nature and what happens
when culture is lost when the
constraints
of morality and ethics flounder and are
torn apart what happens is what happens
all around us
just take a look around as human beings
either through volition or coercion are
torn from constraints
and the comfort of their past as they
find themselves on the lowest rung of an
economic ladder that goes nowhere
in a sea of alienation and disaffection
out of that
comes all the points of crisis around
the world
so the fight for the integrity of
culture is not a rhetorical fight
it's a real battle and we have to fight
and people will die
it's not about the twiddling of thumbs
and i want to remind everybody that
we're in this together
no one has monopoly on suffering
but the bottom line is this we still
live
in a world of conflict and when we live
in a world
where the people in gaza are being
bombarded by the day
live in a world where a million ubers
are in chinese
prison camps and concentration camps
where the forest of the penang has been
laid waste and with it
a whole way of life morally inspired
inherently right
with an extraordinary knowledge of that
force has been swept away in a single
generation
anthropology must re-take
the challenges of our time it has to
take on the
the the the mission of boaz and his
people we must be the
the activist warriors who stand up for
the integrity
of all peoples of all cultural
expressions of every point of one of the
human imagination to be found in all
parts of the world
and now's the time to do it a time when
the languages are being lost the forests
are being cut
the systems of life themselves
compromised it is only humanity that can
find its way out
to a brighter day
you